the violence in the American cities
meant it's got to stop two friends of
mine in New York City they're trying to
get home
two people very private people love
being under the radar
Prince Harry Meghan Markle they're being
chased
in a high-speed chase
all throughout New York City
now many people uh have denied this
happen including the person driving the
car
including the cab driver driving the car
in the New York Post had basically said
uh not really but I get it because these
two and again I'm I'm turning I'm
starting to like them now I for a while
they were annoying to me but now they're
see sometimes when people are in the
Press constantly they become annoying
because they're trying to push a
narrative that we know isn't true like
that they were victims of something
living in a castle and they had no idea
uh what they were getting in she didn't
know what she was getting into I married
his Prince and I'm in a castle and then
the Press wants to see photos of the
baby I had no idea things like that
would happen it's like yes you did you
did you do stop it so we know she's a
fraud she's an actress she's a
cold-blooded serpent so is he there's
Serpentine now
and they're annoying they were annoying
they were annoying and we were sick of
them but we talked about them because
they were fun and then they started to
uh lose relevance of course so what they
did was they cooked up
this thing this false flag where they
were going to try to simulate his
mother's death in New York this I like
this I think is good this is something I
think took creativity it took some type
of planning
um uh we all know that Princess Diana
was killed probably by MI6 who knows
maybe by others but she was dating Dodi
alfayad and that was a no good no-go for
a lot of the people maybe interested and
maybe the Press killed her in the tunnel
but that there's all kinds of you know
there's all kinds of inconsistencies and
whatever who knows the world's uh
complex so I don't know exactly who did
it some say am I six the Messiah it's
probably everybody's maybe involved with
that I don't know but they she died
exactly that way apparently supposedly
may be kind of sort of being chased by
the Press
so Meghan Markle
and Prince Harry are now putting out a
uh false flag attack
the the Press was chasing the mall
through New York City in a high-speed
chase that endangered both of them and
it was similar to Harry's mother and
this is a great way for them to get back
into the news and to engender sympathy
which is something they're Addicted to
You know people can get addicted to
sympathy they can get addicted to this
this is a fact I know people that are
addicted to sympathy you ever met
someone who's like parents died and then
after a while you're like enough
it what happens is people get addicted
to sympathy they get addicted to people
feeling bad for them they like walking
into a room and they like the hush tones
of people feeling sorry for them because
it makes them it's two does two things
immediately number one it makes them
interesting because whatever is
happening to them is interesting and
horrible so it makes them a sympathetic
figure but it also makes them
interesting it gives their life uh
something it didn't have before a
meaning of purpose I am the person that
you were to feel bad for I've gone
through so much you wouldn't understand
you could never walk a mile in my shoes
so people really like this feeling and I
would guess and I'm no doctor but I
would guess that Meghan Markle and Harry
certainly Megan I don't know what he's
even doing he doesn't even know either
but Megan has gotten addicted to this
this idea that uh this woman is a
Hollywood actress uh who's on a show
Suits and her life became interesting by
stepping into this role and then
rejecting it immediately and claiming
that she had no idea what it was
um and so then it's but then they moved
here and they released that documentary
on Netflix and it went the other way
they thought well everyone's gonna feel
bad it's like Britney Spears we've let
her out and it went the other way we're
going back Clank because we've now seen
the results Megan and Harry thought they
were going to come to America they don't
understand America America has a
tragically short memory number one so
even if they did come over here uh as
refugees as migrants uh we'd forget
immediately which we did uh South Park
destroyed them the worldwide privacy
tour
um his book you know sold a lot but it
was like a nothing Burger who cares and
people just got sick of them they came
they rented a big mansion in Montecito
uh in Santa Barbara a couple hours north
of L.A and they uh proceeded to be
annoying to Dad a big deal with I
believe Netflix and then there was a
Spotify deal so they came to America
rented a mansion and immediately started
to monetize the horrible things they had
gone through
um and and everybody eventually got sick
of them because it was so crass and
everybody could see immediately what
they were both about they're hucksters
that's what they are and I love a good
huckster there's nothing wrong with a
huckster but we can see it it's it's
right out there in the open for
everybody to see they came here and they
want to hang out and I know people in La
that know them and all they want to do
is hang out with celebrities and I was
at a celebrity party the other night
talking to somebody about this and they
go these people are just it's constant
with them they keep they were she was
texting the person I was with there they
caught and no you can't come but it's I
shouldn't have even been there but the
point is that they just won't stop these
two they were they're at the San Vicente
Bungalows they're all God forbid you
stay out of the Beverly Hills Hotel and
I'm eating my souffle for the love of
Christ so help me God so help me [__]
God I see that ginger [__] you stay the
[__] out of the Beverly Hills Hotel it's
probably too old school and conservative
for you anyway stay the [__] out
um but they are Just Like Moths To The
Flame trying to hang out with select
they're like the they're like low-grade
reality stars that are trying to attach
to anything and I'm literally the party
they're showing me text of this woman
begging people to like hang out
she's trying to get places it's sad
and a lot of it isn't working and
they're rolling their eyes to me and
they're going LOL and we're all having a
good laugh about this because they're
just a bunch of goons and no one cares
now listen at the end of the day I
respect the hustle I get what she's
trying to do I get what they're trying
to do but it didn't work right and a lot
of people at this party like hey man you
know we text her back we try to be nice
you know she's The Duchess but we've had
enough right we've had enough of her and
she's you know it's enough so what they
did now in New York City uh the city
um that I lived in for many years my
home
uh they've decided to invent a narrative
where they uh somehow are being
dangerously chased through the streets
just like uh Diana would have been
chased
and the NYPD rained on their parade too
quote the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
arrived at their destination and there
were no reported collisions summonses
injuries or arrests okay the taxi driver
who ferried the couple home after their
event Tuesday at the zig Field Theater
told the Washington Post he would not
call it a Chase
adding that he felt safe they got
followed you know why they got followed
because their entire lives are about
sucking all the attention out of
anything that they are involved in
that's why a lot of these people at this
event the other night didn't want them
there and they didn't want to be around
them at other things it's like all they
do is try to suck the oxygen and the
attention out of everything they're
involved in because it's about them and
their cockamami [__] story that the
British royal family was running around
the house with the Noose and it's not
none of it's true it's all uh Canard
it's crap and everyone knows it and so
they're becoming it's becoming like a
it's the she is two years and maybe not
even two years away from being on a real
housewives franchise
she may not want to hear that but sister
friend you and I'm not saying that
because you're blackish I'm not saying
that because you're black I'm saying
that because I use the word sister
friend a lot because it gives me it
feels like a little weight and
credibility and gravity to what I'm
saying I'm not racializing it please
doubt
but I'm saying sister friend that you
are two years away from being on a real
housewives franchise
that's the fact your your tanking in a
major way you're going down
so they invented this uh thing where
they were chased in the high-speed chase
in New York it's uh yeah because there's
seen how to Die Hard where him and her
the NYPD assisted the private security
team protecting the Duke and the
Dutchess a spokesperson said
there were numerous photo photographers
that made their transport challenging
the Duke of the Duchess of Sussex
arrived at their destination and there
were no reported collisions blah blah
blah blah
you know here's the deal
listen to this by the way Harry 38 and
megan41 left the ballroom where the
former suits actress was honored by
Gloria Steinem at the woman of vision
Awards Gala
with her mother Doris Ragland at around
9 50 p.m flanked by both private
security car and NYPD it's going to come
out they hired the paparazzi to do this
by the way soon that's the next thing I
don't know if that'll come out or not
but that's with that's the next step
is that they hired the paparazzi to do
this but
we wish them
well